INGRAHAM ANGLE."
>> Laura: IT'S FRIDAY AND THAT
MEANS IT'S TIME FOR FRIDAY
FOLLIES.
FOR THAT WE TURN TO FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND ARROYO.
ALL RIGHT, WE PLAYED A LITTLE
BIT OF PRESIDENT BIDEN SPEAKING
TO THE TEACHERS UNION.
WHO ELSE IS HE GOING >> Laura:
AT THIS POINT?
THERE WERE SO MUCH WE DID NOT
SEE.
>> YOU WEREN'T ALONE APPARENTLY.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU SOME IN
THE MEDIA AND THEIR REACTION.
FIRST.
AND THEN WE'LL SHOW YOU THE
SPEECH ITSELF.
SEE IF THIS SQUARES FOR YOU.
>> HE SOUNDED LIKE A CANDIDATE
IN A WAY I HAVEN'T HEARD HIM.
HE EVEN WAS WANDERING WITH THE
MIC.
HE COULD'VE STOOD AT THE PODIUM.
>> IS A LOT MORE REPUBLICANS OUT
THERE TAKING CREDIT FOR THE NEW
BRIDGES THAT ACTUALLY VOTED FOR
IT.
>> SAY HI TO ME.
WE GO BACK A LONG WAY.
SHE WAS 12.
I WAS 30.
AT ANY RATE.
>> HE SOUNDS LIKE A CANDIDATE
FOR PSYCHOLOGICAL AND COGNITIVE
ANALYSIS.
COME ON.
IF ANY OTHER CANDIDATE, ANY
OTHER POLITICIAN DROPPED LINES,
DROPPED --
MADE NO SENSE WE ISSUE THESE
VERY BIZARRE REFERENCES TO A
12-YEAR-OLD AND YOU ARE 30, THEY
WOULD BE WRITTEN OUT OF TOWN OR
FRONT PAGE NEWS.
IT'S NOT THE SAME FOR JOE BIDEN.
>> Laura: HAPPY BIRTHDAY DEAR
LA LA.
HE COULDN'T SING THAT.
[LAUGHS]
I'M SORRY.
I KEEP THINK OF THAT.
HE DOESN'T REMEMBER THE NAME.
THE HAPPY BIRTHDAY SONG.
THE U.N. WAS A HUGE STORY.
>> NOT ONLY BECAUSE IT GIVE THE
PRESIDENT ANOTHER PLACE TO GET
LOST BUT IT MARKED THE EMERGENCE
OF A NEW POSSIBLE REPLACEMENT
FOR KAMALA HARRIS.
PEOPLE WONDER ABOUT BIDEN'S
ABILITY TO RUN AGAIN BUT GIVEN
HARRIS' PROCLIVITY FOR WORD
SALADS, AND UNDERSTUDY MAY HAVE
EMERGED.
NATIONAL YOUTH POET LAUREATE
AMANDA GORMAN AT THE U.N.
>> THE DEPTHS OF DEATH, DESPAIR,
DISPARITY, ATROCITIES ACROSS
CITIES, TOWNS, COUNTRIES, LIVES
LOST, CLIMACTIC COSTS.
STRANGERS TO ONE ANOTHER'S
PERILS AND PAIN.
UNAWARE THAT THE WELFARE OF THE
PUBLIC AND THE PLANET SHARE A
NAME.
EQUALITY.
THE OLDEST PRO WE OWE EACH
OTHER.
THE CLAIMANT FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES.
>> GORMAN HAS A WAY OF MAKING
COMMUNICATION AN OBSTACLE TO
COOPERATION.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT SHE IS SAYING.
SHAKESPEARE HAD A GREAT ACTOR
WHO INTERPRETED HIS WORK.
IRVING BERLIN HAD ETHEL MERMAN.
GORMAN IS MISSING THE BOAT BY
NOT RECRUITING KAMALA HARRIS TO
READ HER NEXT OWED.
I BET SHE WILL BE THE PREMIER
INTERPRETER OF AMANDA GORMAN'S
WORK.
JUST WATCH.
>> Laura: THEY HAVE THE SAME
CADENCE WHERE THEY...
[LAUGHS]
NONE OF IT WORKS.
>> THEY STRESS ON THE WRONG
SYLLABLE.
IT DEFIES AUDITORY
COMPREHENSION.
>> Laura: IT'S BAD LIKE
MARSHALL MATHERS OR SOMETHING.
RAYMOND, TELL US ABOUT THIS
STORY WHERE GEN Z-ERS ARE GOING
BACK TO WORK IN KIND OF UNUSUAL
CLOTHING.
>> SURE FOR ANOTHER THE PANDEMIC
IS OVER, THEY ARE DRESSING UP
FOR THE OFFICE.
THE PROBLEM IS THEY CONSIDER
THIS DRESSING UP.
FOR MANY, DRESSING UP IS GOING
TO THE CLUB.
THEY ARE TAKING THE CLUB TO THE
OFFICE.
I ASKED SOME NEW YORKERS WHAT
THEY THINK OF THIS TREND.
IS THIS APPROPRIATE?
>> NO, DEFINITELY NOT.
YOU ARE EXPOSING WAY TOO MUCH.
>> I WOULDN'T WEAR IT BUT I'M
NOT A GEN Z.
>> YOU CAN DRESS FUN AND
FASHIONABLE AND STILL BE MODEST.
>> THEY SAY THAT THESE DRESS
CODES THAT YOU AND I APPARENTLY
ADOPT, THOUGH THEY ARE OUTDATED.
>> I THINK YOU LOOK AMAZING.
>> IS IT OUTDATED?
NO, NOT FOR WORK.
>> I AGREE.
CLASS NEVER GOES OUT OF STYLE.
>> ♪♪ OR YOU HAVEN'T GOT
STYLE ♪♪
>> I WOULDN'T SAY ANYTHING.
I WOULD THINK IT'S
INAPPROPRIATE.
>> IT'S DISTRACTING.
>> IN YOUR OFFICE WITH THIS FLY?
>> IT IS TOUGH TO COMMENT ON
THAT.
YOU DON'T WANT TO GET YOURSELF
IN TROUBLE.
>> YOU DON'T WANT TO CONSULT
H.R.?
>> I WOULD HAVE CONSULT H.R..
>> YOU ARE OBSERVING THE DRESS
CODE.
>> THE ONE ON THE RIGHT IS EDGY.
>> YOU LIKE THAT HEMLINE?
>> I CAN'T COMPLAIN.
>> WHAT THE HELL IS THAT?
>> A DRESS.
>> SAYS WHO?
>> CALVIN KLEIN.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE UNDERWEAR.
>> I WOULDN'T WEAR THAT TO THE
OFFICE.
>> A LITTLE BIT OF HISTORY.
QUEEN ELIZABETH WOULD AGREE.
>> I AGREE.
THAT'S HOW SHE GOT
PRINCE PHILIP.
>> NOT MY STYLE.
>> NOT MY STYLE EITHER.
>> YOU WOULDN'T LOOK SO GOOD AND
THE STOCKINGS, I AGREE.
I WOULDN'T WANT TO SEE THAT.
LAURA, I WAS STUNNED BY THE
NUMBER OF MEN WHO WERE RELUCTANT
TO COMMENT ON THIS.
EVERYBODY IS WORRIED ABOUT
GETTING IN TROUBLE.
IT REALLY IS UP TO THE LADIES IN
THE OFFICE TO TEACH THEIR
YOUNGER PEERS THAT THERE ARE
STANDARDS IN THE OFFICE.
THAT'S FOR THE BETTERMENT OF
ALL.
>> Laura: RAYMON